i filmed a cooking show with jd and he
was great i filmed he made a cooking
show
that's going to be released
what's going on john tell us about that
it was a test screening yeah it was a
presentation pilot it's uh jd cook's
sandwiches
jd has wonderful chemistry wonderful
charisma i'm too lazy to cook i'm too
lazy to learn how to cook
and he was a latchkey kid
i recorded him making a beautiful
sandwich
and
it was incredible
it just tastes good there's no like
i don't know he was articulate
passionate engaged and it was his true
being his true self he just talks about
his love for sandwiches and i think it's
a great piece of information for a lot
of first of all latchkey kids who want
to learn how to kind of entertain
themselves when they're alone and jd why
are you upset when he refers to you as a
latchkey
he just keeps it's like his buzzword is
like he constantly says it every time he
said it 50 times while we were filming
it what's it like to be a latchkey kid i
mean it's it is what it is do you have a
message to latch key kids out there how
to not get bored no they're fine back i
keep saying how i watched julia childs
when i haven't watched julia childs ever
used to watch julia childs and secret
joe is that not true it's just not true
but you're lying it edits it into the
video i watched julia tiles i watched
julia tiles i watched julia tyler okay
he when he shared with me when we were
in los angeles how much we shared with
you julia childs anything about julia's
child i never watched julia child
stop
yeah
child or child
let him do his thing okay i just said i
i might start mispronouncing it that's
all he said it so many times one of the
things i heard about this cooking show
robin is that
the jd uses an inordinate amount of
mayonnaise i would have made it it was
crazy
i love mayonnaise and when i my fat days
i put mayo on everything so i'm not
judging but i've never used as much mayo
as i see jd puts mayo on both sides of
the bread on both sides of the meat so
it was like four health beans well
there's cheat you know cheese on top of
the sandwich so you put on the cheese
and you flip it over and do it on the
meat
and then both pieces of bread yeah
and your special technique what you do
with the sandwich before you eat it is
you put it in the uh sometimes if it's
roast beef especially i'll put it in the
microwave but but you know the microwave
that i filmed with was very it was very
uh
high powered and it ended up melting
everything pretty much
so it didn't go so well